When I was talking to Dr. Chi last week, he said not to take vitamin E with cancer as that can allow the cancer to cross the brain.
Have you ever heard of that? He also said not to take niacin with cancer.
I don't remember the reason that you mentioned B vitamins before any cut into that.
Well, I would disagree with him on the vitamin E.
Higher dose vitamin E is what's in the ACOP E that we use has been shown with multiple studies to be beneficial for all kinds of cancer.
In fact, I think I cite multiple studies on breast cancer and vitamin E.
Higher dose vitamin E like that is oxidative and it's been shown in multiple times to be cancer preventative and cancer killer showing the disagree with that.
Diacin with cancer so I think the thought process is taking high dose diacin can dilate your blood vessels.
Thereby the thought process I'm thinking maybe I'm completely wrong with what he's thinking would be if you die if you're dilating your blood vessels that you're that you're you're getting more.
If you will source to the cancer, but I just would disagree with that as well.
If you're dilating your blood vessels then you're also, you know, you need the your immune system to your cancer better your oxygenated your cancer better which is going to kill the cancer.
I don't agree with that.
What I've said about the B vitamins is methylated B vitamins because methyl groups will turn off genes that will silence tumor suppressor gene so in every cell including cancer cells, you have a genetic.
I'm through meditative that is supposed to be turned on to kill the cancer which stimulates the intrinsic apoptotic pathway so.
And that is the tubers tubers suppressor system so God given tubers suppressor system turns on.
When a cell becomes cancer of school equipment nucleus is damage that starts reproducing this happens literally probably on a daily basis in all of us.
Your tubers suppressor system then kicks out and the cells go through an intrinsic pathway of apoptosis killing the cell.
That's why we don't all have a diagnosis of cancer so you methylated you have access metal groups with silence those genes can turn those genes off.
And I don't think we should do that when you have cancer.
You only you have to look at other factors too.